Can I help you?
Why Yes, yes you can. I'm here to report a terrible crime.
And what terrible crime is that?
This one!
Aw sh*t. I told this all wrong. Quick history lesson.
And soon enough.
Psychologically speaking. Vengeance rarely brings
the catharsis we hope for.
yeah
Are we ready?!
You named him Bruce? After that hunky Wayne guy.
Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie big surprise.
They dropped the brand-new birds of prey trailer
so we'll break it down there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs, a couple more Batman name
drops more Joker name drops as well as black
mask in full comic book black mask.
If you're new to my channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the Easter
egg videos we're doing a movie to giveaway
to all you do to enter is be subscriber and
leave your favorite Harley Quinn moment from
anything on the video.
There was an interview little while ago that
Margo Robbie did about the film explaining
what's going on with the Joker how this relates
to the other DC films and how they tell the
story of this film.
The important thing with the way they're telling
this story is that most of the film is nonlinear
jumping all over Harley Quinn's timeline until
you get to the third act then it becomes a
linear so it's a sort of Harley Quinn being
this unreliable narrator telling you her own
back story jumping around from event to event
the kind of did the unreliable narrator thing
with Joaquin Phoenix is Joker movie were you
not quite sure whether or not you're getting
the truth because you're getting it from his
perspective.
The whole time with so that they're using
a little bit of that type of storytelling
for the Harley Quinn birds of prey story.
The song the plays across this entire trailer
is Bjork's cover of its so quiet which is
a cover of a Betty Hutton classic show tune
from 1951.
They did the same thing with the last big
trailer you have Harley Quinn doing Marilyn
Monroe from gentlemen prefer blondes, which
was also covered by Madonna later sued of
the entire movie is going to be like this, or
they just engineered the trailers to work
this way, but Harley Quinn's pageantry is
like level X during this seriously for most
comic book movies you expect the main characters
to get a couple costume changes or some upgrade
but because this is Harley Quinn you get like
10 different outfit changes in fact most of
the other birds of prey seem like they were
the exact same outfits of the entire movie
Harley Quinn is probably the only one that
shows up every 15 minutes in a completely
separate outfit the opening scene of the trailer
seems like it's her rescuing one of the other
birds of prey from lockup.
It's not clear which Police Department.
This is because later in the trailer you find
out that Renee Montoya is basically being
kicked to the curb because she's trying to
investigate black mask, so the rest of the
police department is giving her the middle
finger laughing at her for trying to take
down black mask makes them seem kind of dirty
so don't know what's going on with this particular
precinct and where Commissioner Gordon is
in all this.
Most of the time when you see a dirty precinct
in a Batman story Batman winds up taking that
precinct down with the help of Gordon they
give you little more context for her back
story with Joker leading up to the events
of this film because this is coming after
the last suicide squad film and in that post
credit scene Joker shows up to Bell rev to
break her out see you kind of wonder what
happened in those couple years between these
movies but if it wasn't clear.
This is obvious he taking place after the
last suicide squad film, but probably before
the next suicide squad film the James Gunn
is doing that film will also feature version
of Margo Robbie's Harley Quinn I'm assuming
it will be set after the events of this movie
but that's not totally clear yet.
So what is worry about it when it's our dropping
footage for the next suicide squad film, but
this is basically Harley Quinn blowing up
ace chemical to cortical break up with the
Joker two things we could probably assume
here.
She did not leave a note and she did not actually
kill the Joker she just blowing up his quote
of quote home base and a lot of you are also
asking where is the Joker.
How does he figure into this movie.
Are there any scenes with Jared Leto's version
the Joker just for continuity sake Margo Robbie
revealed that there is no Jared Leto anywhere
in this film.
They did use a body double for some distant
scenes but you don't actually see the Joker
himself on screen.
So you would be able to tell that it's not
your Leto playing the Joker, but is meant
to be his version the rest of the trailer
is dedicated just explaining what the actual
story is why they come together why black
mask wants to kill every single one of them
as she says during the trailer turns out,
when you're not with the Joker anymore a lot
of people want to kill you they're all terrified
of the Joker the clown Prince of crime even
black mask.
So now that she's not with Joker anymore.
She's basically saying that they declared
open season on Harley Quinn just look in the
background for second to it the way she's
decorated her apartment.
I we see she's throwing knives at the picture
of the Joker in the back like us is it meant
to be the Jared Leto version the Joker, but
she's at the stuffed animal Kleenex holder
right next to her to give you little more
the black mask plot obvious either running
Gotham city imports and the McGuffin of the
film that diamond that Cassandra Cain winds
up swiping it sounds like she just pickpocketing
and she doesn't know what it is she steals
to way later like she sees this giant diamond
is like holy crap what is grad from this dude,
this is Christmas and as victors as character
victors as obvious you know from the comics,
but he's second in command in the movie to
Ewan McGregor's black mask with her making
sound like the biggest criminal at least right
now and got them in this trailer like there
obviously lots of crime families and got them
during the events of the film black Masters
happens to be the most powerful this her to
introduce the other birds of prey characters.
This is Helena Bertinelli Huntress.
They explained her the trailer she wound up
killing one of black mass best friends they
don't say who that was.
So you just left a wonder I'm guessing at
some point during the film someone will reference
who that was with going to be some big Batman
comic book character over the most part it
seems like she's a pretty authentic version
of comic book Huntress comes from the Bertinelli
crime family but then rejects them answers
going around killing mobsters one by one.
This seems like it's coming from.
Much later in the film.
This might be after she bussed her at a prison
so maybe it is Cassandra Cain who's in that
lockup when she goes in the beginning of the
trailer you can kind of use the trailer footage
to chart the timeline of the movie based on
the different outfits the Harley Quinn wears
because like I said there are many different
outfits.
This is a very Deadpool asked scene of Harley
Quinn trying to fight this biker gang off
inside this evidence locker, but she sits
behind this giant pile of below then inhales
that in his very Deadpool asked who I'm touching
myself kind of moment.
I have a big plan in then that things go completely
off the rails.
If you think it's weird to see Harley Quinn
doing drugs in the trailer it's probably because
the movie is rated R's with going to be a little
more hard-core.
Even though this trailer is a green band version
of the trailer the biker gang takes a face
full of blow.
So even though she just kicks the crap out
of them.
You have to imagine that by the time they
go down.
She says that dues beard on fire.
They are probably high is kites more them
cutting loose in the supermarket having fun
doing a big shopping spree getting food and
also getting food for the hyena is a giant
bag of dog food in their the you can't see
we finally get an answer about what's going
on with black canaries Canary cry truth that
she is a med Ewan during the trailer.
So whatever continuity you think this version
of Gotham existed within the Batman movie
mythos.
There are still meta-humans.
I mean we still have characters like the flash
so people do have biological powers is they
didn't make that really overtly clear from
the last trailer, but here you actually see
her using her sonic canary cry to one break
that class while she's singing, but also to
take than that giant group of black mass villains
in the parking lot later Harley Quinn says
she pretrade black mass but it's not clear
what she did to betray black mask all the
stuff of them inside the amusement park is
taking place on amusement mile which is always
a very seminal location within the Batman
mythos for the Joker in the Harley Quinn character
love the way they all react to Huntress's
unbridled rage way more black mask suiting
up in a couple different costumes and a bunch
of different sequences also more of the false
face Society gang wearing their mass to we
see them in the previous trailers, but they
just give you much better look in this trailer
they show you her and Cassandra Cain getting
some burritos.
It looks like just enjoying the smell with
the hyena in the back was she's named Bruce
after Bruce Wayne, Batman is not clear if
Batman is going to be featured anywhere during
the movie.
I'm not expecting him, but there's this Bruce
Wayne reference.
I'm assuming there's maybe a couple other
Bruce Wayne references or the big guy the
back guy babies offhanded Batman remarks without
directly referencing Batman were in a weird
place cinematically with our version of Batman
because they're making Robert Patton since
the Batman movie right now we actually seen
him on set technically the Batman of this
movie should be Ben Affleck, but it don't
know if he's going to be featured in any of
the future movies.
Even the flash flashpoint movie that they
just announced there also a lot of people.
After the last trailer that claimed that there
were two hyenas in the back of her car, but
this clearly shows that there's one hyena
in instead of it being Bud and Lou from the
original animated series those of the two
hyenas that she has during that she might
just have the one hyena Bruce for most of
the movie.
Maybe she gets another hyena at the end of
the movie to use when they change things like
that is usually for the sake of practicality
like you have a combination of different types
of special effects to pull off the hyena in
the scenes.
Some of the scenes with it seems like their
animatronic like when it's in the bathtub
laughing after she references Batman then
because there's a grand tradition of Harley
Quinn unleashing her hyenas upon people that
she doesn't like the place scene where she
use that to maul someone that apply be full
CG that some of the roller derby Harley Quinn
scenes.
I don't know what kind of roller derby she's
doing during the course of the film.
Maybe that's just something that she picks
up in her free time after she's not with the
Joker anymore, but they going to turn into this
big roller derby action scene later when she's
trying to rescue Cassandra Cain from black
mask in his car.
The funny thing about Harley Quinn in this
scene here when she's talking to Huntress
about her rage.
You have to remember that Dr. Harleen Quinzel
was actually a psychologist at Arkham
Asylum before she became Harley Quinn she
was the one that was brought in to psychoanalyze
the Joker before he wound up twisting her
to his ways and she became the Harley Quinn
character.
So just because she's been Harley Quinn this
whole time doesn't mean that she still not
a really good psychologist.
She can psychoanalyze all these other people,
so maybe she does some of that during the
film they got into a little bit of that back
story during the last suicide squad film,
but she's just been in full Harley Quinn costume
going crazy like comic book Harley Quinn for
so long as you kind of forget that she actually
used to be a really good doctor is a big montage
of action scenes from previous trailers that
we've seen from across the movie that she
looks to camera wall back in her car breaking
the fourth wall so does Sally should be breaking
the fourth wall little bit during the film
little bit dead.
Not quite the way that Deadpool does it.
The funny thing about the Deadpool in the
Harley Quinn characters as they kind of use
them in similar ways in the comics to comment
on the action of whatever stories that there
in breaking the fourth wall is they both debuted
relatively close to each other in the early
90s Deadpool came first and new mutants.
Number 98 in 1991 Harley Quinn debuted the
next year in 1992 on Batman the animated series
in the episode Joker's favor if you not the
comic book reader Harley Quinn is actually
probably one of the most famous examples of
a character in the comics that super popular
in present day that did not debut originally
in the comic she debuted on the TV show.
Everyone loved it.
So they brought her into the comics, everyone
loved it even more and she wanted to become
even more popular over time, but everyone
let me know in the comments if he spotted
any big Easter eggs in the trailer that I
didn't mention in the video I will be doing
review videos Easter eggs and everything for
this movie when it comes out next month I
will do a new video about the flash flashpoint
movie there's a couple big trailers that it
just drops will try to get all the videos
as fast as possible, including the crisis
on infinite earth stuff also name a giveaway
winner when I posted next trailer video so
everyone click here to learn about Batman
himself Christian Bale showing up in Thor 4
love and thunder and click here for my
last big Marvel New Mutants Trailer!
Everyone stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!